touché par des par des personnes que
j'ai rencontrées et puis
n'importe qui et moment donné peut être
touché moi ma cause en tout cas ce qu
est ce qui prend mal etc tripes c'est
les enfants l'enfance
et l'idée de donner le maximum de
chances à chacun de réaliser son
potentiel maximum voilà c'est ça à la
base katusha mois donc forcément 7,7
correct
[Musique]
un moment donné donné un petit peu
d'énergie sous différentes formes soit
ça parce qu'on a envie d'organiser ça
parce que envie d'être présent échangés
soit sous forme aussi effectivement
financière c'est aussi l'énergie donc
pour pouvoir soutenir cette cause est en
tout cas nourrir ce combat contre la
maladie voilà pour aider leurs enfants
et leurs familles vous aussi fatale dont
le 2 et 3 décembre dans la hâte
rendez-vous
[Musique]
la réunion tel est ton pays nous défient
contre la maladie